[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
welcome back to everyone and welcome to
those of you who have joined us
um for the afternoon session um
and uh we are going to go
i think straight into the next
presentation which is
a presentation by andrea kim
the title of andrea's presentation is
the myth of post-racial avatars
anime girls and the shojo ghost
and the cyber shaman in virtual worlds
and i'm going to pass it over to fox to
introduce andrea great i'm really
pleased to have the chance to introduce
andrea because i think it's
not only a fascinating but important
thesis so that she is completing and uh
presenting on today
you know so it's important for a number
of different reasons
i think one is the fact that
many people formerly saw virtuality as a
nice to have
but as evidenced by this meeting here
today it
seems to have become a must-have in so
many parts of our world today but that
also means there's
a convergence of what these platforms
impose upon us and
and how they allow us to mediate our
identities and selves
in virtual spaces and some of the ways
that these
that these spaces do so are through
pre-constructed characters
through the kind of environments through
the the logics that include logic
logics of colonialism military
industrial complex and
much more that uh you know that again
mediate how we present ourselves in
these
spaces so this this convergence
of the ways that virtuality
has become a must-have along
with the the kind of commercial
spaces and the ways that they impose
constraints upon us
and then sadly also have to say this
particular moment
and the types of violence and prejudice
that exist including the recent
terroristic
attacks against asian people and asian
women in particular
all come together in unfortunate ways
but ways that we also have possibility
to revise
and do better so the reason i said that
andrea's work is
important is because it calls attention
to this convergence
the impacts and the nature of it but
also points
towards a way out of this and towards a
way that people's identities can be a
positive resource
for the future and a positive resource
towards moving beyond violence and
prejudice and towards a place of
creative
and empowering self-expression for the
social good
so i'll leave it at that but i hope that
you will join me
in welcoming andrea kim to present on
her thesis work
thank you so hello my name is andrea kim
and i'd like to introduce my master's
thesis the myth of post-racial avatars
anime girls
the shojo ghost and the cyber shaman in
virtual worlds
so the avatarized anime girl can reveal
much about how cultural phantasms are
actively produced in virtual worlds
not only through the users but through
the computational system itself
phantasms describe how our mind body
complex blends sensory input
such as the anime avatar that reflects
aspects of a particular worldview
such as that of such that shoujo girls
are innocent cute to feminize objects of
affection
phantasms are only semi-visible and need
to be revealed
otherwise they're taken for granted
they're also mysterious
people cannot pin down precisely how
they came to be possessed by a
particular phantasm
this is a concept put forth by professor
harrell who is the advisor to this
thesis
also with dr monda haibun delger on the
committee thank you both for your
thoughtful guidance for this research
so the topic of my research i examined
the cultural production of anime girl
avatars in vr chat
to understand socio-technical relations
to virtual world making
specifically i focused on world making
in the social vr platform vr chat
world making is a term i draw from
anthropologist and playwright doreen
kondo who uses the term to describe how
structures of power
labor processes and performances of
subjectivity are linked in the theater
industry
thinking about making and unmaking of
racial constructions for instance
in my study i aim to deconstruct
cultural biases embedded in social vr
and explore the potential of social vr
for digital performance
i ask how does social vr mediate
embodied experience and what
opportunities does it present for
reorienting our approaches to virtuality
for methods i employ the phantasmal
media approach which encompasses an
analytic method and a design practice
which are both within the scope of this
study i also used ethnographic methods
informed by critical theory to immerse
audiences into social vr
to consider broader implications beyond
the medium
i think it's important to note here
that also the studies focused on
english-speaking users in vrchat who are
using the
referencing shoujo as anime girls as
well
as for findings i discover that cultural
biases are embedded into
the social vr media ecosystems at a
socio-technical level
meaning that the materiality of digital
spaces acts upon users and their
behaviors
first social vr embodies new media
logics that produce and mask phantasms
that affect social relations
second aesthetic and data structures of
mmd-based avatars are intertwined with
values that reproduce tropes about asian
femininity
and reduce bodies digital physical femme
asian or otherwise
as manipulable objects of the colonial
male gaze
in this thesis i argue that being anime
is not a post-racial
conceit but one built from a situated
cultural imaginary
that erases the bodies of asian girls
and women in its construction of virtual
personhood
a key insight emerges here we need more
intersectional feminist design of
digital avatars that make apparent the
racial and gendered power dynamics in
virtual world making
but also we see an opportunity social vr
offers new possibilities for identity
play and transcultural learning
when engaged with a multi-disciplinary
practice grounded in values of care
i applied these findings to a design
component for which i am developing a
working concept of
cyber shamanic performance to draw from
practices rooted in cultural memory
to inform virtual world making this led
to the design of a vr work called a
place of care
which responds to our contemporary
moment in regards to violence against
asian women
so a place of care on march 16th a month
ago
on this day eight people were killed in
a mass shooting in atlanta
six asian seven women as a korean
american researching representations of
asian femininity incidents like this
remind me of the deep-rooted cultural
violence affected upon migrants
immigrants and asian women in america
this writing by yin kyu a labor activist
articulates my shared sentiment
as they write massage parlors where
people are given touch
intimacy where you lie your head down to
sink into yourself
where a massage worker cares for your
body and tries to heal it
he shot a gun into a place of care not a
religious space but certainly a sacred
space where you feel human and humbled
so a place of care invites participants
into a massage room
to engage with their effective relations
to that space
it invites users to address the fear
stigma or misperceptions learned from
mainstream society about bodywork
especially from asians and immigrants
participants can experience the massage
room as a place of healing and memory of
the lives lost from this
senseless violence in this work i draw
from popular storytelling practices that
center voices in the margins
so social vr back to social vr and why
now
here we have some popular social vr
platforms alt space mozilla hubs
facebook horizon
um we see social networking like
facebook converging with vr
as a consumer product as we see with
these images of headsets
throughout my research and social vr for
the past year i've been to film
festivals experimental theater shows
pole dancing and club venues
a course at harvard and many other live
event spaces
finding solutions to programming halted
from the pandemic
and 2020 has definitely been a big year
of experimentation in social vr
and the platform in which i conducted my
study is vr chat
vr chat additionally to creating and
attending a variety of events users can
build their own avatars and virtual
worlds in unity and import them into
vr chat they can build studios or live
stream a talk show go world half popping
and there is a robust community of
makers and freelance artists
ugandan knuckles which is a viral meme
and video that caused vrchat's
popularity to
spike in 2018 is a phenomenon that
demonstrates the performance
of media culture in avatarized form but
also in the way that it reproduces
racist behaviors
uganda knuckles remixes a character from
the sonic franchise with a meme
into a 3d avatar that users can use
usually to troll people with
racist about african people hatsune miku
is also popular
a virtual idol with a huge global fan
fan base
and furries in the furry fandom also use
vr chat to meet up with friends talking
taking their media and very embodiment
practices into avatarized forms
so not only are characters performed
through avatars in vr chat but
also through various media products
the theoretical underpinnings digital
media studies cultural studies and
feminism theories can offer various
angles from which to consider
mediation and social vr so digital media
studies gives us insight into the
interface between vr and human cognition
media convergence and the cultural
logics guiding emerging in media
cultural studies presents
techno-orientalism
coined by morley and robbins and drawing
from edward saeed to just to refer to
discourses emerging after world war ii
responding to rapid economic
developments in japan um and shifts
in global power techno-orientalism thus
reverse refers to the idea of the orient
that type cast asians as less human
components
of techno-virtual worlds to conquer
techno-orientalism assigns technological
and thus inhuman characteristics to
asian people
and is an expression of desire to reify
global imperialism through technology
and so in this image we see some
cyberpunk imagery that predominates
popular notions of futurity
and finally i draw from feminist and
sub-alternate theories that emphasize
situated and relational knowledges
feminist and self-sub-altered practices
bring worlds into views while critically
interrogating the mode of viewing
concepts like onto ethics or onto
aesthetics onto epistemologies refer to
the inextricable link between being and
knowing
and and like relational ontologies they
require us to consider that
those apparatuses of knowing
in terms of method i entered
in the spirit of situated knowledges i
employed auto ethnography
but my auto ethnographic experience was
marked by
disorientation and not the
deconstruction of self
as much as the construction of self so i
went on and off your chat over the
course of 10 months
and interviewed with 10 vr chat
community leaders
and and world makers interviews focused
on the makers hosts and content creators
and such
um from the phantasmal media approach i
apply two approaches to
to challenge negatively um bias to
phantasms
one is um to reveal phantasms by showing
them from multiple world views
such as the assumptions in each or such
that the assumptions within each become
clear
and secondly creating empowering
phantasms that
through developing a design practices
phantasms are a cognitive term that call
attention to
how phenomena are only semi-visual
describing how blending
sensory input and a concept rooted in a
particular world view produces a new
idea
so the phantasms of others are often
seen only partially
seem only partially knowable
this mysteriousness is used often to
support justifications or explanations
of behaviors such as
asian women are submissive because they
are from a patriarchal culture
so with phantasmal media in mind i
analyzed the mmd
3d model as a data structure from which
the anime girl aesthetic
came to be and the systems in which they
are intertwined
so really quickly for those of you
unfamiliar with social vr or vr chat
here are some of its affordances
um with virtual reality we've got single
view perspective
perceptual realism um meaning that
the representations on screen are like
represent our replicating um perception
outside of vr
and there's a sense of heightened
presence as well social vr
um is digitally you have digitally
embodied social presence through voice
chat or graphical avatars
you're spatially close to to others and
there's the element of
network community connectivity and so
when you look in the mirror uh in terms
of uh the affect
or the technosensorial relation between
our bodies and our avatars
studies have shown that when you look at
the mirror
and have a moment of self recognition
the pairing of the gestural movements
and the visual continuity of your avatar
increases a sense of
embodiment and identification with that
avatar figure
now these affordances of heightened
presence
also come with some risks
um issues of harassment predominate uh
the early years of social vr and there
have been reports
that come out um that articulate the pt
how ptsd can be triggered um through
social vr um and so
we have here a performance by michelle
cortez who
um is a designer for facebook social vr
platform
to design it um in a more sensitive way
that
keeps account of bodily autonomy and
prevents
issues of serious um harassment and so
in this performance piece
she um spends four hours to question
different like avatar
anime style avatars to like in an
investigative way
and to see what they have to say um her
her performance focuses more on the user
agency side of the question of wanting
to give
face to or give voice to the the the men
behind the image
um and her findings from this was
that they were predominantly had
performances of heteronormative
masculinity and also instances of
sincere gender play
so my first finding is that social vr
embodies new media logics that produce
ambiguous socio-technical links between
the avatar and virtual world
the main point here is to think about
how the new media logics of immediacy
and hypermedia see
our intention social vr embodies this
paradox in a way that masks how it
operates
the bodily effect of immersion from vr
aims to erase the medium
through realism um while this avatars
and vr platform itself makes it known
that it's vr chat
virtual reality or the metaverse as they
self people self reflexively call
the vr chat world it is embodied in a
way that the avatar and sociotechnical
system are linked at an inherent level
and so these are kind of three examples
that show that inherent
link but between the avatar and socio
technical system
one is that blocking users show that
despite the guise of
immediacy of a shared space not all
users see
or hear the same things you can block
users or change the settings
um and the reality is that not everyone
is seeing
the same thing even if they're together
secondly the avatar performance ranking
exemplifies how
it's a metric in which um not necessa
the complex avatars are not necessarily
the better ones but
avatars are kind of valued by how it um
democratizes communication with the
bandwidth with everyone else in the room
and another example is um seen in
avatar worlds or the proliferation and
predominance of the anime girl aesthetic
scene in vr chat it really provokes the
question of why
and and is you know asking people
um this question i'll often get a
response at oh it's the easiest style of
avatar to make
um or there are no good male
anime avatars that i can choose from so
these kinds of um
reasons i think um is what this thesis
instant challenge
so one of my auto ethnographic
experiences stick out to me so
i was invited to a concert of a french
musician by a published
publicist i met at sundance and so once
i got there i felt the excitement
crowds of avatars waiting but around 40
minutes in there was no show
after repeated technical difficulties
combined with people getting frustrated
uh someone in a hatsune miku avatar ran
to the front of the stage and started
dancing in front of everyone
to the laughter and encouragement of
some male users
afterwards i asked about it and the guy
said it was just
i was just clicking the emote button and
i didn't make this myself
almost as a disclaimer the emote button
is so impersonal and detached yet as a
viewer that situation didn't really feel
that way
of course it's the anime girl in a short
skirt who placates the crowd
in this act the avatarization of anime
girls reflects stereotypes about
asian femininity and bodily labor the
digital avatar itself and what
is coded in it produced an affect like
the guy said
he only clicked a button so i want to
think more about the anime girl avatar
as a material object and as an
assemblage of signs
avatarizing desire
even if it is not the user's own it is a
symbol that reproduces cultural
hegemonies
finding two the aesthetics and technical
structures of mmd
based models are tied to values that
reproduce strokes about
asian femme bodies this is known but not
interrogated although it affects social
culture
so by analyzing the data structure i was
able to
trace them the movement and history
across media platforms
the mmd model is a 3d model that
originated from the fan culture
surrounding hatsune miku who is a vocal
software virtual singer
and anime figure who transcends multiple
media forms
using the freeware mmd software which
stands for mikumiku dance
fans could animate miku's bodies into
different dance moves
and upload it released in 2008 the
software is one of the earliest that
allows complex joints and physics
systems for humanoid avatar bodies
for this reason it's been used to make
music videos crowdsource choreography
for concerts user generated pornography
and now in part
the our chat avatars learning tutorials
for how to make vrchat avatar from mmd
model
share more than just the technical
knowledge but also the maker's
attitudes towards their avatar and its
imagery specifications of value
preferences in dampening elasticity
stiffness etc express the desire to pour
control through
technical mastery of particular body
parts humor is also often used to
reinforce this
post packs are pre-made gestures that
animate the avatars and orient the
possibilities for that avatar's actions
which include play and touch of body
parts
or the flowing movements of long hair
moreover mmd-based avatars rely on
pre-existing media's infrastructures
such as repositories of user-made models
such as on like nikoni solid
there are a lot of freelance artists
hobbyists devoted fans who built up this
open and participatory culture and it's
really quite
incredible um so
in many cases the act of building an
avatar from scratch contributes to the
feeling of ownership and
identification with it but culture works
algorithmically and the stereotypical
features of these media representations
carry on to the space in subversive ways
i've used a shoujo schoolgirl avatar
once um
to go through this process and only in
vr chat did i realize that when moving
around
people could see up its skirt in a way
the claim that the mimd is the most
convenient and easy
yes avatar it is partly true here but
there's there's more to it
so thinking beyond the anime girl a
phrase used by english speakers of vrc
let's consider
the concept of shoujo and bishojo more
broadly
so shoujo is a term that means a
japanese term that means girl or young
woman and typically
refers to the audience of shojo manga so
adolescent girls who are the drivers of
these culture
the imagery of the shojo figure across
east asian cultures and consumable
culture
refined notions of asian femininity the
pure virginal maiden who is
simultaneously sexually empowered
like vrc space the spectacle of mixed
signs and interpretations
the transnational mediascape of shojo
are also complexly intertwined
in an allison's study of japanese toys
she articulates how
the material production of media are
tied with and global fantasies
as tomiko yoda says of girl culture in
japan
objects are immersed in a mediatic
ambiance blurring the distinction
between the manufactured
product itself and its distribution and
promotion
according to tomiko yoda the history of
girls magazines reflect a transformative
point between girl and woman
becoming a woman is a transformation
with no return with little residue
it is a fundamental paradox of girl
culture that this erasing transformation
is encompassed by
elaboration of the intricately
pleasurable practices of being
a girl becoming a girl if we think back
to my earlier anecdote about the dancing
hatsune miku
my affective relation towards shoujo
imagery
you know we have sailor moon here who is
an incredibly empowering figure young
girls identify with
being used in contexts outside of that
shoujo imagery though has aesthetic
continuities with
bishoujo which translates to beautiful
girl and shifts men as primary consumers
of its artifacts
um and is used as a figure in adult
dating games or in idle figures like
miku so shoujos are not only objects of
affection
they are active agents of stories which
many young people identify with and
understanding
the affective complexity toward the
shojo aesthetic
depends on your global position and
experience with media representation
the proliferation of this ambiguous
imagery transgressing public
and private spaces reproduces damaging
phantasms in virtual and mediatized
worlds
as shojo hatsune miku symbolizes the
fluidity of meanings
attached to media and the different
material forms and lives it can take
so here we see a hologram of miku
selling out concerts
a man in japan also has married a
hologram of miku
so how can we describe this phenomenon
hatsune miku's fan based include otaku
who are young media savvy hardcore fans
of anime manga video games
and came out from the rapid
technological advancements in the 80s
in japan moe is a term that describes a
euphoric response to an intimacy with
these fantasy characters and the
representations of them
moe is an affect in response to fantasy
forms
and typically describe a burning passion
for these young cute
anime girls digital media scholars
consider hatsune miku fan praxis as
democrat democratized participatory
culture of web 2.0
some theorists consider otaku as more
open to other possibilities of becoming
a union between man and machine
a new god that free
transcendent relation to technological
bodies
or a heroin interpretation of a
contemporary cyborg
but what does it mean for a vision for
online participation or a vision for
post-human subjectivity to be
shojo a mediatized girl from japan
i argue that the idea of the anime girl
being post-racial is a myth
shoujo is situated in cultural
representation of asian femininity and
continue to hold affective relationships
with young girls that i
argue should be the active agents of its
aesthetic mediatized or not
especially as we are entering an
increasingly mediatized virtualized
world
the avatarization of desire needs to be
designed as defined as such
moreover global nature of an anime
requires us to revisit this aesthetic
and its potential implications across
global audiences
so another point of discussion is the
global export of asian femininity
and quite literally of women themselves
in the cool japan campaign
is the culture pan campaign is part of
the japanese foreign ministry's brand
strategy to export its media and
commercial projects
products abroad while inviting tourism
here you see kizuna ai
another figure like hatsune miku well
known as a virtual youtuber reaching out
saying come to japan in front of the
unnatural landscape
this type of imagery reinforce ideas of
japan
and japanese women as a site for
exploration here we have the three
ambassadors of cute from 2009 reflecting
the tropes about asian women propagated
by the national
japanese government themselves the
schoolgirl lolita the harajuku style
girl
certainly all discourses related to
shoujo these girls visit various
countries promoting
popular culture so when we think about
techno-orientalism in vr chat it's
critical to consider the economic and
social history of mediatized girls
through the lens of advertising and the
export of these images
technical orientalism is not only a
question of west versus east which by
the way is often used synonymously with
a single country of japan
rather techno orientalism is question of
is a question of global imperialism
and which power is in motion across
national
ethnic and racial lines
so a key insight coming out from here is
that we need more feminist design of
digital avatars to
reveal the racial and gender power
dynamics in virtual world making
social vr however does offer
possibilities for sincere expression
identity expression and play there has
been many uses for rehabilitative
purposes for addiction or treating
mental health for instance as psychology
research has shown
anime girl avatars are also used by fem
transfem identified folks who might be
experimenting with gender expression
there is a and and club zodiac on the
right here it's another
instance club zodiac is a pole dancing
community that uses full body tracking
to perform in front of the rc audiences
while the anime style aesthetic is used
the modifications make
made express user agency in the
adjustments to body types their skin
tones
moreover the use of full body tracking
to dance
strengthens the continuities between the
actions of the avatar and that of the
user
unlike the emote button we discussed
earlier
social vr offers possibilities for
bridging geographical barriers
for a shared experience here's a still
from the immersive theater performance
scarecrow vr chat when i asked
which from a production crew in korea
when i asked the interlocutor of mine
how much of this audience here is from a
film festival and from the vr chat
community
and they said about half half we all
shared this moment through k
art's creative performance
so i now move into my more creative work
um
as doreen condo writes creativity is
work practice method a site of theory
making and political intervention
so here we have the shoujo ghost
and the shoujo goes to me is a character
concept that's still in progress
but as my talk has covered the
materiality of digital avatars hold
agencies separately from that of the
user the shoujo ghost is an expression
of this agency in the form
grounded in memory the mem the story of
the avatarized anime girl
the shojo ghost creates a memory of this
phenomenon in social vr in a way that
informs future world making
from the point of view of animus
mythologies
my concept of the shojo ghost is largely
inspired by the legend of hishindang who
is a virgin ghost spirit and sea spirit
in a fishing
village in jeju korea as the legend goes
heshigan is a young maiden whose fiance
left her on a rock while he was going to
fish
she got washed over the shore and passed
away her virgin spirit
not having fulfilled her womanly purpose
raged over the village
and to appease her spirit the villagers
would erect phallic statues around
her shrine the shojo ghost is a play on
the virgin ghost but also a
re-stratification of this idea
she is the spirit of the avatar's anime
girl in vr chat long divorced
from their origin the shoujo ghost
yearns for techno intimacy and is
satiated only by rituals of
heteronormative sexuality in vr chat
thus her form as ghost actually is her
most pronounced expression of agency
within this condition
and must be exercised in order to
reimagine virtual worlds
so to give some more clarity here i
introduced the idea of
cyber shamanic performance
so cyber shamanic performance is really
centered on the idea of expanding
notions
of virtual world making through
practices that are rooted in embodying
and enacting memory
centering voices in in the margins
shamanism is incredibly broad and
contested term
and is practiced across culture with
regional differences by cyber shamanic
performance i'm referring primarily to
shamanic practice in
korea and its interrelationships to
media technologies that
corresponds with its specific modern
history
shamans or mudang are predominantly
women who are conceived of as carriers
of stories of trauma through korea's
modern history
as healers priests performance and
prophets shamans revive gaps and
emissions and cultural memory through
practices of remembrance
in the buryat context in mongolia manda
haibuyan delja theorizes shamanic
performances as enacted memories
realized to multiple media such as
gesture
language food music and material objects
so shamanism in korea has ties to media
technologies
in this documentary recreation of the
life of the korean wudang kim
kim kum hua the young girl is collecting
scrap metal from our village to sponsor
the artifacts for her initiation ritual
to become a shaman
we see here the self-reflexive inclusion
of the film crew and placing the camera
into the bag as one of the tools
signifying this union between
technologies of virtuality and gestures
of goodwill towards
towards their youths and scishow is a
contemporary
work by hyunji kim um where that allows
you to
it's an exploration this artist uses
cyber shamanic performance to explore
diasporic identity
the ultimate work of shamans in
reconstituting the past is not history
but memory
knowledge of the past that is
emotionalized
embodied and attached to an individual
this brings us back to a place of care
currently a work in progress there are a
lot of values that we can draw from
cyber shamanic performance one of them
being an
emphasis on healing a place of care
brings you into the massage room
it's a place to consider the lives lost
to senseless gun violence and it's also
a place to consider the systemic
dynamics of police violence and
transnational histories
of asian woman body labor
as asian massage workers sex workers and
survivors of human
trafficking continue to be impacted by
anti-migration policing
and the criminalization of their
livelihoods a place of care invites us
to consider the implications of damaging
cultural phantasms about
asian femininity virtually but also
three blocks down to at our local asian
massage business
in this work i draw from popular
storytelling practices
pairing with 360 video of this chum down
here which is a shamanic dance to
resolve sorrow
and transform the pain into reality a
pain
of reality into beauty and concludes
with all participants joining together
collectively
near an ocean shore landscape
so as a brief conclusion um
today i examined the cultural production
of the anime girl
avatar in vr chat to understand
socio-technical relations to
virtual world making i deconstructed
cultural biases in social vr
explored the potential of this as a site
for performing identity
and ultimately argued that being anime
is not a post-racial category but one
built from a very specific and situated
cultural history
and so in terms of future work um i'll
be
doing a fulbright fellowship in south
korea
and my research project is to
investigate how historical archives
folks storytelling and cultural memory
could be a more central part
to virtual world making i'm curious
about how
virtual technologies can be used for
creative educational curricula
and how digital performances can be a
research method or a mode of inquiry
so thank you so much for listening to my
presentation
and i'll stop sharing the screen now
all right thanks so much andrea um
so we're open for questions
william
thanks thanks a lot andrew it's really
provocative and big it always
hearing about your work always makes my
mind like explode a little bit
and um and i'm afraid i have kind of a
question that reveals more about my
ignorance than than anything else
so hatsune miku as you
as you've rightly said gets usually
emblazoned with words like
democratization web 2.0
this is a contributory fan based i don't
know the
empirical work behind it in terms of
gender divide like who makes it and who
doesn't is that
exclusively male fantasy or are women
involved with that
but my question actually connects with
with your
point about the shaman and your this
notion of
memory versus uh history
and i get the critique if miku is kind
of history if it's out there
but it strikes me that it's it it is
emotionalized it
is embodied it is attached to
individuals to the effect that people
contribute to it that contributory
dimension
complicates that character in my mind
anyway so for example the work on
queering
of miku right for for a particular
community that is a very personal kind
of assertion
um it's an embodied assertion they've
taken the time to work on the on the
on the drawing themselves and i'm just
wondering how that
works like this this divide between
history and memory is an intriguing one
it's the shamanic dimension that you
that you mentioned at the end
doesn't miku slide in and out of that
between being out there
and being part of us who produce it
those those who produce it
because it is emotional investment it is
an embodied act
um yeah that i guess that's my question
i'm struck by the for me and this is
ignorance as much as anything the kind
of ambivalence of that
of of that figure um yeah that's my
question
yeah i think this is partly where my
situated approach
comes in because there's a lot i can
read about hatsune miku
being like a symbol for this or a symbol
for that but i think at the end of the
day like the approach that i've chosen
and like thinking about the specific
like imagery that um
hatsune miku or like the way that that
avatar was used in
like the anecdote that i shared i think
is the center point of
this discussion about um what she could
represent as a virtual
ritual idol and so i i would have to
look into
like exactly the distribution of the
gender distribution for who is her fan
base
but um from the readings that i've had
it is largely
driven by like the otaku male fan base
and i think that
yeah but it's less the fan base because
i know there are definitely a lot of
fans it's more the
the creative base it's the it's the
place that she comes from it's the hands
that generate
uh her her figure and it's the hands
that manipulate that figure in
fair enough to take an instance uh uh
but there is like there is some
let's say i haven't read much about it
but i have read is on the querying of
the character
which is a you know a really interesting
again not just fans but creators
so it's that that polyphonic notion of
creativity
that to me helps this character straddle
the the the history memory thing is a
nice way to talk about it
that this is embodied memory for some
people those who have
contributed to making it um whereas for
others yeah it's just a it's just a
thing to look at like
we look at history we're outsiders and
we look at this distant artifact but
okay that's the
fair answer
other questions
well i i have another historical
question and
and that is um just the
the or what are the origins and
again and what are the origins of the
original two-dimensional form
of the anime girl um and
you know what i guess i'm thinking about
um
stewart hall's concept of the historical
conjuncture
right and what you know what were the
various kind of historical uh
forces at play in the creation of that
particular figure
and you know how does that
how does that differ from the present
moment
or the moment where um where the enemy
girl form becomes
animated into three dimensions in vr
worlds
um and so i'm just curious about the
relationship between the origins
of of the figure um in two dimensions
and um and and the the
kind of moment that you're looking at in
your work
um right so i in terms of tracing
origins of i guess the shoujo aesthetic
i
i read um about kind of girl magazines
um in japan and tamiko yoda's work
uh discussed how in girl so i guess like
i was trying to um i was trying to bring
in
these themes from girls magazines um in
the history of kind of like
media for for for young girls um to to
express
um like a ten like a thematic tension
like for instance
um becoming woman is transformative with
no return
and little residue um yet it's and it's
a fundamental
paradox of girl culture um
that erases this transformation um
yeah so i guess i'm if i i think looking
at the history of
shojo will will say that it is um the
audience of it is actually
towards shoujo young girls themselves
and in the form of
girl magazines
oh i have a question um if
i don't know if they're i can't see if
they're hands too
um paul had his hand up okay so why
don't we go paul and then fox
okay my hands blending in with the wall
and
thanks andrea that was great to see sort
of how you brought all these things that
we've
been talking about sort of together it
was really nice to to and i really
appreciated how you brought in
the context of massage and care and
that's what i wanted to ask
more about it's always been striking
hearing
men talk about why they're using anime
girl avatars in vr
in that it's often seems to have a
aspect of care or relaxation or they say
it's
very easy to have people talk to you
because you look a certain way
or there's a kind of soothing quality
not confrontational quality
which of course as you describe is
completely over determined and
racialized and
um and has all that context around it
but at the same time it's often
precisely along these lines of care
or affect of labor or a certain kind of
emotional uh association with the form
uh that comes through so i was wondering
if you could maybe elaborate a little
bit on this larger context you're
drawing out of
if the the anime girl avatar is actually
a tool of care in some context or
could actually play a role on the same
kind of effect of a restorative level
but then you're also drawing out this
other context with the performance of
the
the the space of the massage and also
the kind of shamanic ritual space
as well i was only if you could kind of
yeah where
where the the avatar fits into this uh
question of care and care work
yeah thank you i think um yeah
um in terms of like you know the
emotional affects
um and and feelings of care towards um
these uh like moe and towards anime
girls
um i think that's totally you know
it's certainly an expression of care so
yes i would completely agree with that
but i think
a question comes like towards you know
how what happens when these types of
visions for care
um you know in vr chat
through the anime girl it doesn't feel
accessible to
other people who might have like
reactions against
that aesthetic so i think like my
project is really speaking
towards the need you know looking at
these phenomenons
um in embodying embodying different
anime characters
um like i mentioned you know the
possibilities for
gender play using these anime characters
or
you know other instantiations of user
agency and
empowerment but um yeah so
but i guess like my project is searching
for kind of
um alternative visions as well to that
are like inspired i guess by you know
these instantiations of
virtual personhood which certainly are
instead
like they are certainly virtual
personhood um
but are you know made in spaces of
exclusions
fox yeah sure so i want to just to ask
andrea just if we could explore a little
bit more about this uh
the idea that say the you know the
anime girl character could you know can
be
sort of reappropriated by communities
for empowering
or even transgressive kind of purposes
versus it seems like a lot of what
you're arguing about is that
there's still a kind of resonant
violence that is often done
especially for a lot of asian female
users within the space
and what it makes me think of you know
so there was a paper
in a mit press book written by simon
penny the robotics artist
and a professor where he describes one
exhibition that he he mentions as
unfortunate and ill-conceived and so
the way he describes it and i'll say
there's a mistake in the way he
describes it i'll mention it in a second
but
he describes it as a work called can
schwann
by alexander brandt and it's
a interactive work in which there is an
asian woman
who is nude lying face up projected onto
a life-sized crumpled crop
cloth on a stone floor in a dark corner
and the only thing users can do in this
interactive exhibition is to stomp on
this projection
and it's interactive in the sense that
she will then recoil in pain and so
forth and eventually even fade away
so he critiques it as being a work
that's
created by a white male and something
that is uh you know it's a work that
is seen as oppressive and like based in
colonial fantasies and much more
actually there was a mistake in his
analysis ken schwann
it was the artist who was asian female
artist
and alexander brandt was the curator or
gallery owner
and so there was a mis-reading that was
there but i think it's telling because
still the resonance like regardless of
the fact that there was a kind of
reappropriation
of her own image within the work it was
still read in this kind of
in this kind of oppressive way and it
seems to be related to what you're
saying that
if people just want to take up an image
that has some kind of
violent resonance or connects to those
histories even if for them it feels
somehow
kind of redemptive or empowering in the
world it might not be because somebody
else going to the gallery wouldn't feel
what the artist felt when she created
that work and it seems to me that's
where the kind of the kind of insights
of manduhai and the
and your work are important that it's
not enough just to take up
the avatar and then within your sub
community to use that as some kind of
empowerment work
the shamanic practice seems like it's
doing the additional work thinking
through
what really has to happen in order for
it to be transformative
in a broader sense for other visitors in
the space and
yeah and and not just a kind of an
internal one and so
that's yeah in some sense yeah
commentary but i also wonder
if that resonates with how you are
seeing the shamanic work
is sort of going beyond just communities
reappropriating imagery but trying to
make sure
that it actually does the work that they
intend to more broadly
right i think thank you so much for that
comment fox i think um
yeah i think my work once is responding
to
um the fact of um exclusions in in
virtual personhood and
it's it's to me i think that alone is an
argument
against why it is a form of virtual
personhood and and we have to consider
kind of like
the you know more popularized i guess
more
a truly democratized form of virtual
personhood
i i argue looks would look different and
so
yeah and i and with the shamanic
practices being rooted in
um giving voice to um more like
marginalized experiences or
you know being a carrier of popular
knowledges and stories
um i think yeah that resonates
there's one more question before we move
on in
in the chat that is from diane kim
congratulations on the fulbright andrea
i would love to learn more about how you
want to carry out the project in korea
what are some topics you're excited to
explore
yeah so i i've been really loving kind
of um
digital media performance using social
vr
so i'd be curious to um think more about
how
social vr can be used and fourth yeah
for theater
or um in
um you know and and i would love part of
my work in fulbright um
involves um ethnographic work in
different like mask dance um uh
masculine um traditions um and so
i think it could be interesting to think
about how like
ritual objects are built or like
artistic um
objects are built that have a more like
ritualistic
history um and think about how that
relationship to
to materials can be used in um
the virtual reality context as well so
coming up with
new design principles um that are more
rooted in like
um like performance practice practices
like mask dances
um and how like the the
costumes or objects are prepared
excuse me um thank you so much andrea
and let's have a another round of
applause wonderful work